is this one linker in a little bit no I
just got to get a little high you just
[ __ ] blew my [ __ ] hey what's going on
everybody four first we feast I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching hot ones the
show with hot questions and even hotter
wings and today I'm joined by Action
Bronson we're here
he's got ancient aliens going on [ __ ]
that's delicious you can catch him on
vice land and now he's here with us
action welcome to the show thank you
that was a beautiful introduction how
are you with hot food I'm I'm well
trained some would call me a Mexican I'm
from Puebla alright well you ready to
sum the [ __ ] mountains just action
right now I hear a lot of talk I'm not
over here claiming I'm gonna go over and
[ __ ] eat all this crazy [ __ ] but I'm
gonna you know I'll do well
no I don't understand
I got a word I'm not I'm not worked up
yet I want to start off by talking about
ancient aliens are you really into the
subject matter or yeah it's a fun show
the walk in your hi yes and yes what are
the things that you're into
I like structures wild art and
architecture I like just old [ __ ] what
blows your mind the most is that the
pyramids
sunrise sunrise wonder when the Sun
rises over the mountains and you could
just see it peeking that makes me it
mesmerizes me that I'm astonished by
that this is the [ __ ] boggle mentum
boggled this can't all be a coincidence
something no it's not top-of-t all right
yeah it's upper tiers a good one I like
this classic yeah it's a nice flavor
this actually brings a lot of pizzazz to
what I had last night my lady brought me
home some roasted chicken some Colombian
roasted chicken some white rice and some
beans just throw a little in there and
it just kicks it up it brings it to
another level party
so you're the sort of surprise entry
into this pantheon of great TV hosts
it's a crazy [ __ ] thing there's no
explaining it because I say this a lot
but there was a time where I was
watching these people damn like I want
to really be on this street I want to be
at this level and then it's all like
it's just all bull it all kind of made
its own Road and exactly interesting but
I'm sure that you're inspired by some of
the OGS so what I want to do is show you
some of the most iconic TV chef
personalities and I just want to get the
first thing that comes to your mind okay
laptop please please I'm an old school
kind of guy so I hope you got some good
ones I think I got a destiny I have
legends I have legends here action I
wouldn't undercut you I hope you [ __ ]
start with Martin Yin okay well if you
don't start with Martin Yan then don't
show me anything okay if I don't start
with Martin Yan don't show you anything
so guess I'm gonna start with Martin
[ __ ] yeah Martin Yan Yan can
cook talk to me about Martin he thought
everyone he saw white people how to make
Chinese food
your boy mario batali I mean I kind of
looked like this guy for some reason
when I was like like now I drew some
sort of similarity to him I don't know
something about the orange cracks it
makes all age groups like him
the orange grab a little he's relatable
I don't know he's he was very
interesting in the way he spoke very
theatrical he's just is mesmerizing guy
this [ __ ] guy right here died from
Yeti man he's a legend there's no doubt
about it he's a [ __ ] hardcore legend
that's what he is the thing that gets me
the most is this bleached there's a
natal touch who did that for him does
that takes precision Martha Stewart I
like her alright so it's like a food
interview can I ask you why Tina Garden
is not on there you know which is on the
list we had a list of like 10 him we had
to cut it down really you know he [ __ ]
up by leaving her off the list I gotta
be honest with you wistfully but there's
main side
where's Jacques pépin are you out of
your [ __ ] mind with Jacques touré he
told me how to make chocolate what are
you doing with this what's going on
sorry actually I just like my thing
figure it out this one is all you can
check out what your five and you know
what's my deal I don't know but what is
your deal I don't know what do you do
what were you about where do you come
from how do you look what do you of that
what do you do just a dude that he
swings and interviews famous people
that's it come on it's not absence to
you I'm not an energy substance in you
you're the star of the show
you're who people are interested in I'm
just sort of you know it's just you're
the part of me I'm sick e-poll babes I
hope you rocking it out there thanks
babe I'm sick fool that's the first time
I've ever heard that [ __ ] one mmm
there's a hot sauce on a lot of
Caribbean restaurants a lot of Dominican
restaurants lot of Jamaican restaurant
social this performing shows getting
exhausting
with all these copycat people that you
have to suplex off of the stage cuz I'm
sure that was fun when it first started
now it's probably getting kind of
annoying it really was fun I love doing
wrestling moves on people I love to slam
people I love to perfectly do a judo
throw you know when you just get that
perfect leverage and it's like
effortless when you hit the baseball and
you just you don't even feel it you just
hear this goes but I think at first it
was like fans that were kind of in on
the joke with you and they did it and it
was fun for them but then I think it
kind of got to a point where people were
like I'm gonna go to this show and try
to fight action bronson it kind of
turned into sort of a fun thing into
kind of a fight for your life that ever
feel like that for you yeah you know
just when someone creeps up on you from
behind it's weird you know a lot of
these [ __ ] venues they should be
providing the security which they did it
that's right you always have to do it
yourself that's you know and it's not
right because that leaves me liable for
a lot of [ __ ] and I'm not that one
you know there's just I'm just
protecting myself someone comes in here
right now I'm just [ __ ] clotheslines
you it'll be [ __ ] up right big time
and I can't protect myself
no we take care of it I'm starting to
like you more and more you are yeah I
appreciate that action what are your
go-to videos to watch on YouTube when
you're high honestly I've been into
Grey's Anatomy a lot yeah how do you
[ __ ] two hooked on Grey's Anatomy
really a little late to the party
a little late to the plywood what do you
think I'm gonna be [ __ ] in the street
21 years old watching Grey's Anatomy
that's it now I'm here chillin at the
crib in my underwear with my dog and my
lady you know I watched Ray's Anatomy we
have a thing if I watch him without her
she gets upset and you guys like talk
about the show anymore - Tina Karev
who's your favorite character right now
I'm [ __ ] with dr. Bailey dr. Bailey's
our favorite character himself she's a
tough exterior but sweet on the inside
really good at what she does I could
probably do a couple of hard surgeries
on somebody
for sure a running whip stitch
so this is the hot ones hot sauce yes in
Mike body so he could come make an
appearance yeah yeah this thing homeboys
what's up buddy
you leave me hanging so homeboys makes
it they're a hot sauce maker in Phoenix
and then heat Ness distributes it there
that hot sauce store no no heat Ness to
do so we work together it's a collab
homeboys heat nest the first we feast
together hot ones good little sweet you
have any questions for body
dude we should read your DMS or camera
when did you come to terms with baldness
like when did you decide because I'm
kind of I don't know like maybe I should
let it go shoes to steal Alchemist his
face oh I wasn't ready for this I wasn't
ready for that
nobody you have to start off smooth body
you can't just roll right out all this
you tried to open the door now you're
walking out what I've broken that door
down cuz you have to understand I come
from burglary oh so I'm used to coming
in windows and sorts of exits no no I
thought I was in the beers done but I'm
not saying alright so this next part is
called explaining that Gramm and what
we've done action is we've done a deep
dive on your Instagram we've pulled some
pictures that we just needed more
contact so I'll show you the picture
maybe body you can Kobe Shaq this yeah
and you just tell me the bigger picture
what's going on here does that sound
good
absolutely action what the hell is going
on here you took the golf cart is this
oh did you took it you took a piss in
the middle of your set this is the same
show but no one caught this one on
camera this was a even crazier hijinx
they threw they try to arrest me for
this this was in [ __ ] Ottawa
I stole the [ __ ] golf cart while
rapping after I had just taken the piss
and I'm just riding through a festival
of children and you know I'm driving
crazy erratic but I'm under control
because I'm a driver I've been whipping
since 13 I can talk about yelling
Cherokees and
No you know one hand driving my the
other hand is on my dick the cool off
because this happens every once in a
while
got a good off huh yeah for sure waters
theatrical splashing of water at the TV
it does especially when it's all over a
300-pound man sweaty buddy myself
it is you know it's the water sometimes
they got the tapes you could just hear
waterfalls or oceans yeah just look at
what or animals just just yeah that's
the same thing that's like that's a
soothing picture if you have a bad day
you look at that picture and you know
you know everything's gonna be okay this
is interesting you and the captain are
not meeting Derek Jeter [ __ ] I
couldn't I couldn't have had a better
experience meeting someone that I look
up to you know sometimes you meet people
and you're like [ __ ] why'd I meet that
person I hate them now I can't I can't
look at what they do I can't listen to
what they do they've ruined it all for
me right this man is the exact opposite
he gave me a [ __ ] hug and embracing
hug talk to me for a little bit told me
he liked me told me that I could keep
going like what like tell me what could
get better about that picture I have
mother [ __ ] driving gloves in the
breast pocket of my car heart standing
next to the captain because I'm a
[ __ ] sportsman at hard man I [ __ ]
play sports my entire life you could put
me in any arena right now and I'll do
well very athletic it's known it's a
known thing we don't have to boast
this one sauce freshly sauced High River
Road shout-out to body for helping us
out I like this one hmm from all that
I've read about [ __ ] that's delicious
this is not some paycheck project for
you you're very over vested you're very
interested in the magazine stuff my
progr
obsessed with the process absolutely
you're right I'm [ __ ] obsessive about
everything I'm crazy I have to have I
need every bit of information possible
what do you think is the greatest food
show of all time
I mean probably no reservations because
it really it was like the culmination of
everything that everyone was doing made
into one what a very smart dude a
cool-looking dude and the cool do pretty
much there's different levels if there's
a cooking like actual cooking like so
like multiple Mario's my favorite
all-time show it's intuitive it's it's
everything it's everything it's smart
it's funny it's everything it's like a
good a good a good play what are the
things that you roll your eyes at the
newest style stuff where it's just like
people are so [ __ ] boring and you
don't know where these people come from
what makes them an expert it makes you
want to cook their food and it's not
real [ __ ] you know I'm [ __ ] pissed a
lot of time of the day you know so are
they right I don't want to see you smile
mad big on TV while I'm making a [ __ ]
so delicious custom meal that looks like
slop I'm good on that
is this one linker in a little bit no I
just got to get a little high you just
[ __ ] blew my [ __ ] what are you
smoking
I don't know somebody gets this town can
pay it's a mystery pen I'm not mad at it
let me charge anything over there what
do we need a USB here yeah I got a USB
let me just charge it in the computer
action first time I was gonna bring down
walls here I was gonna bring the [ __ ]
yeah you know what else cause you always
have like such crazy glassware yeah look
at the toys I do I have toys I like toys
me when we smoke outta you vape most of
you vape do you do like edibles and
stuff what's your na hit very expensive
glass pipes in my house in my underwear
do you like collect em and stuff the
ideas that you [ __ ] it you know how
sneaker hazard collectors of sneakers
and that hoarders I'm I've been that way
with glass pipes the past year you have
a favorite one Yeah right now I got this
buck and wjc collab it's a [ __ ]
anglerfish it's like this big
it's a [ __ ] fish you [ __ ] hit it
here comes through here and then comes
through the spine triple perc action Wow
a wild one time very this shop with
Tommy Chong and it's like a full-blown
art scene where they're like glassware
artists and that's what it is can run
like ten thousand fifty thousand dollars
do you smoke out of them or some of them
like you valuable touch everything I
don't give a [ __ ] if it's a honey k is
getting smoked out of we're putting labs
through it
this is the bomb beyond insanity thank
you action welcome oh and you get some
of those subs in there you see that yeah
that's skin contact that's how you know
it's that good good
so I once heard you say ask what is
being said don't just write it down
you're talking to the people on genius
who annotate things so what I've done is
I've pulled some great Action Bronson
food references and I'm gonna hit you
with them and I just want you to
annotate them genius style just tell me
what's going on here okay yeah that one
shooting slow no careful run your eyes
you already know that though mm-hmm
don't touch your dick differ that's a
big one that's a big one only veterans
know that I've done it know that mistake
but this one's from one of your favorite
Action Bronson songs Terry
ruff mr. wonderful twist it off to jacob
watch Aniyah chef the secret e3d it was
right yeah it's a play on how crazy [ __ ]
gets that's what I'm doing I'm meeting
lines neck and I'm definitely not
huffing jenkum that would be a bad move
I think so starting to hit yeah no I'm
just my eyes I'm low I'm low I'm not
ready for those yet right now though
it's gonna get crazy we'll talk how
about one from uh from tapas off blue
chips all right but I'm gonna expect
lunches from the phone right to the
table and straight to the plate I doubt
you cook with late farm-to-table air to
plate you know take something vegetable
like from here right here put it right
there mm-hmm while the duck is flying
I'll just [ __ ] grab it and lay it on
the plate for me that's what my life's
about imagery and what ways does writing
rhymes affect the way that you talk
about food and vice versa because it
seems to have a connection maybe I'm
reading into it no it's not it's all
about the comparisons you draw like I've
lived life I've lived a lot of life so I
could draw comparisons to a lot of
things with a lot of like the milk is aw
it's like [ __ ] from Finland or some
you know like a beautiful pasture
[ __ ] I don't know what I'm
saying but you know what I mean like I
could
I can come through with some imagery
that a lot of people kids I've lived
life a lot of people haven't lived life
so this is mad dog 357 oh that's a big
mad dog bite from Action Bronson
little chicken in the beard that was
amazing all you gotta do is shake it out
piggybacking off that last thought you
got it you're someone who's passionate
about food I'm passionate about
everything you have such a unique
perspective when you close your eyes and
you think about a dream restaurant
action Bronson's restaurant what does it
look like what am i smelling what's on
the menu
what's the vibe it's a little paint the
picture for me it's a little edge stout
little piece on a corner maybe some
Wickery two tables out front two inside
me behind the kitchen me in the kitchen
going doing my thing oven with wood
burning you love those words but I love
burning anything with wood burning is
gonna be good you know you're gonna get
that essence of the boom the carnal the
carnal desire what are you serving
whatever I wanted changes every day what
if you were opening it today or do you
have an about to push 100% barbecued
with big Gigante beans probably doing
some sort of [ __ ] pastrami sandwich
I'll also do it piece some sort of duck
where is it isn't in New York is it
someplace else it's in Queens it's in
Queens on Jamaica Avenue it means a lot
I feel like the one before that Mad Dog
was the hottest Wow we do have one more
we do
this one is Megadeth sauce with liquid
rage it's got a little champagne on it
because if I miss a perlier you want to
open it now it's not gonna pop I guess
you could open it now if you want to I
guess it didn't need to cook into the
kid and what it is it's tradition around
here to dab the last wing so I'm gonna
do it I don't like to pressure people
action just a little drop on will put a
little bit on the button I'll [ __ ]
Shamir it okay smear that's a pickle
schmear
that's dabbing which you just did is you
topped I topped it
yeah that's not dabbing so dab is to
this tab okay
hold dad from action no but I'll dad
that was just giving you an example of
would've dad giving me a little
technique action all right good
yeah come on here come on this one man
nothing [ __ ] really crazy like you're
handling it better than I am oh yeah a
sweat I'm fine over here I am I know
that Dominique put on too much hot sauce
who [ __ ] Dominique Wilkins ooh
Dominique in the room in what ways do
you get annoyed when celebrities chefs
rappers jump into the food world and
they try to do their own thing in the
culinary world without much of an
expertise without much of a know-how
without much of a history it has to
drive you insane I know you're probably
gonna play it cool but it has to drive
you insane I'm gonna play it cool but it
has to drive you crazy no cuz there's a
link this is a new lane this is an
uncharted territory I opened it up and
now here we are like other musicians and
actors and this this is the way it is
now anyone could do it anyone could do
it but they can't do it the way I do it
that's it how do you do it differently
come on man I [ __ ] do sold-out shows
all over the world all over the world
[ __ ] thousands of people rock and
screaming my name
and I go eat elegantly and there's
[ __ ] best restaurants and I cook I
clean I do laundry I clean my own dishes
you feel me I still do the dishes at my
house because you like it if there's
something because I'm a [ __ ] real
person as if someone else is supposed to
be doing the right action you made it
through yeah yeah we out here ten wings
and this was a heavily sauced episode
for the folks at home action a little
face weapon otherwise incredible
composure this camera that camera that
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life action I got a
book coming out next year [ __ ] that's
delicious the book I've got a [ __ ]
new album coming out I'm working right
now [ __ ] that's delicious
every Thursday ancient aliens all over
the [ __ ] place you could watch it off
at all times as marathons on Vice Lynn
all the types of things going on on
munchies I feel like I just took the
[ __ ] craziest bump of lidocaine
[Music]
I feel like looking at a moment it's not
a Mona Lisa I'm more avant-garde more
more weird
I'm weirder than a Mona Lisa